foreign
election day is finally here and so is
presidential front-runner rila odinga
[Applause]
Nairobi stronghold as his supporters
hail their chosen leader
he's here in kibera to cast his vote one
of the largest slums in Africa
[Applause]
whose residents witnessed some of the
worst post-election violence in 2008.
foreign
people are going crazy over him I mean
this is his fifth time running for the
presidency there's a huge investment in
him winning this time and you know this
crowd as excited and euphoric as it is
we just saw earlier how easily it can
turn we've been voting for a long time
and you have not seen him to be a
president but now he will be our
president now
hours earlier and Miles up country
odinga's main opponent William Ruto cast
his ballot before light even broke it is
upon all of us respect the choices of
the people
and the people of Kenya turned up to
polling stations bright and early to
make those choices unfazed by cameras
and thousands of observers flooding in
to monitor an election that is seen as a
test of African democracy
you can see by yourself things are calm
it's orderly
that's all that the people of Kenya need
the dense crowds and long lines dwindled
as the day went on and with an hour left
to go just over 12 million cadians cast
their ballot 56 of registered voters the
candidates that's going to get the most
votes in Kenya this time around I think
is going to be apathy could that apathy
actually lead to a peaceful election if
people aren't as emotionally invested
well I think the thing to understand
about election violence and kidney is
that it's not spontaneous it's a it's a
system a systematic coordinated funded
at the highest levels and and so it's
not so much the people that people
should be worried about it's the people
who have power
Halls have now closed and the country
anxiously awaits the outcome
is tasked with
key closely
Sky News Nairobi